hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 99 of game
programming we are really getting close
to upset 100 now and I'm running out of
ideas as to what to do to celebrate that
massive occasion so leave a comment
below if you guys have a wild idea but
nonetheless episode 99 we're going to
talk about nodes also I've kind of
changed the way that I'm recording this
I used to actually record like my entire
screen and then zoom in now what I've
done is I've I'm just recording a
session on my screen and that's just
because sometimes I forget that I need
to zoom in onto something in like
post-production and I won't do it and
then like I won't show what I'm doing
and mess so um I've done this this way
all right I'm just empty my recycle bin
real quick so let me know if this is
better or worse I don't know you know
I'm just ma'am mixing it up for episode
9 you're on alright so nodes last time
we did vectors and nodes are gonna be
based on the vectors essentially so what
does a node well I've got this little
program here so I can build windows in
the right way and I'm just going to
basically illustrate to you what our
deal here is so basically basically like
if I just rate what we've got going on
with our game right now yeah we've got
like this that's really not very hard to
press harder I suck at this we've got
this let's just pretend that this is our
game world all right obviously we're
using tiles so thus we have a grid and
these are all of our different tiles
that we may have in our map in our level
right let's just say that this blue will
be a player
okay players right over here all right
that's the player now this pink hair
purple as I call it is an enemy or
rather a location that the entity wants
to get to okay so blue is an entity and
pink here or purple is the location of
where the entity that's clearly pink I
don't know why they call it purple maybe
I'm
blonde that's like the location that we
want to get to okay that is the entity
that's where we need to find a path to
of course we are using the a-star search
algorithm if I didn't say that at the
beginning I don't think I did but
basically to get from point A to point B
here we need to somehow figure out a
path using their the a-star search
algorithm now what are nodes well this
is interesting it's where it comes into
play here I know it will be marked by by
the color red here I'll actually just
switch to a paintbrush that might be
easier paintbrush okay that is it
so we've got this we've got this
situation here where we're gonna get
where we want to get from point A to
point B now a node is essentially I
guess a waypoint
think of it as a waypoint right and a
Waypoint being at location that we can
technically go to right so if we look at
our entity here well the world is tile
based but we can move you know in pixel
precision essentially but we definitely
don't want to make every pixel a
separate node because that would be
awful for performance so what we want to
do we want to break it down well can I
go here can I go there and because we
have a situation in our game engine
right now going on where this is more of
a in depth kind of feel with this
diagram but I hope you guys won't mind
too much we've got this kind of
situation going on where we don't have
any kind of 1/2 tiles right so in other
words a tile is either a tile can only
be one type and one type only so we
can't have something like a wall that
occupies half the tile basically if a
tile is not solid it is a valid tile we
can be there we can we can cross that
tile obviously if a tile is the wall we
got a problem and that's the main thing
that we want to fight against don't we
tiles that we actually can't physically
get across so because right because
every tile is all we need to know about
that area we can simply assign a node to
a tile so one tile equals so one node
equals one tile so in that case all of
this all these things they're all nodes
right every tile is a node
including that one I'm someone's not
gonna put a red one there this is also I
know by the way this blue thing I'm just
not gonna literal with that so all these
are potential candidates now let me um
grab my pencil here real quick again so
and I'll make the color green so in
order for us to get here the a-star
algorithm can actually examine each of
these waypoints right so you can say
okay to get here in the shortest amount
of well the shortest path possible I'm
probably gonna go up here the green it
was a bad choice I'll just make it black
we want to go up here maybe then maybe
here and then well there we go that's a
pretty short path right there yeah we
can go like that it does that now we
can't go like that
that would be ignoring the nodes
basically a node of course is an area
that we can go to okay now there might
be a wall here if this is a wall a star
says okay well I can't go there right it
checks all the adjacent nodes and we'll
talk about this later but it checks all
these nodes and it says okay I can't go
here but I can go here so I'm gonna work
my way around here and find out as a
path but the point is it needs these
nodes because it needs to know where it
can look for a path and we're assigning
a node equal to a not to a path equal to
a tile here because because that's what
week that's the best way that we can do
it right now now you might also notice
that I've put nose in the middle not in
the top left and we'll probably talk
about this later but when we have a tile
the air the coordinate of this tile in
terms of pixels where it starts is
always gonna be up here because we start
rendering from here and we go this way
and then we go with basically scan it
like that don't we but we start up here
now for nodes is very very common to
want to put that origin into here for
obvious reasons but I and one of the
reasons as well because they might not
be so obvious for you guys is if a
entity here which is going to be this
little smiley face is moving across
multiple tiles we don't want him to be
moving in the corner so we want him to
kind of be moving through the Centers of
the tiles because it just looks cool
okay that's another example but
essentially each of these nodes the way
that we're going to store them and I
went over this last time the reason we
even needed back to coordinates was
because
was because of the fact that tiles
aren't like tiles don't know where
they're located right the location of a
tile is not stored in the tile we only
have static instances of tiles a grass
tile there's just simply just one
instance in the grass tile it just gets
it just gets drawn multiple times so
because of that tiles no idea where they
are
we need a system to work out where they
are so we use nodes for that and nodes
of course the position of a node is
going to be stored as a vector 2i and
that's where that comes in so now let's
switch over to our code I hope you guys
enjoyed that I I really do want to do
more stuff like that with diagrams and
stuff let me know if you guys want me to
because I think I might just make one
off videos that aren't part of any
series that deal with topics like that
and actually illustrate them and talk
about them in depth I really wanted to
do that for a while the you know my
holidays are coming my university is
finished not for the year so I might
just do that
over the break so a nerd should probably
belong to a level as well yeah
not really a utility because I know it
kind of is the part of a tile and that's
kind of a level thing so I'll
right-click here hit new class you guys
are the drill and I will go ahead and
call the class node all right and a node
needs separate and there's a bunch
there's a bunch of things the first
thing a node needs am I gonna make all
these fields public by the way the first
thing in node needs is a vector so node
node needs a location so usually would
go ahead and do like that I'll begin X&Y
we're not going to do that we're gonna
go ahead and say public vector 2i all
right and we can call this location and
we I'm just going to call it ty on the
reason I want to call it tile is because
a node is supposed to represent a tile
this will just make it a bit easier for
readability and of course I'll import
that in that class we also need to make
a parent node now this is interesting on
explain this in a minute and then we
need three little calculations that a
star will use called F costs G cost and
H cost this is a great time to explain
this thing isn't it
well let them make sure that's a double
yeah okay so let's actually just write
up the constructor first and then I'll
explain everything later so we need to
specify a tile of course we need to
specify a parent node we need to specify
a I didn't close that good I didn't we
need to specify a what else are all the
costs I guess except for our F cost and
I'll tell you why in a minute
edge cost all right so we'll do the
normals thing that's not Holocaust tile
to stop parent equals parent of their
start G costs equals G cost and whoops
make sure you write it out in the same
case there's not H costs equals H cost
right and then that just leaves F costs
what on earth is f cost well F cost is
actually the combination of G cost plus
h costs so we can simply express that as
this dot G cost Plus this top edge cost
now you could um remove this and I would
refer to the parameters but it's
probably safer to do it this way just
because we might want to fight outside
of the function for some reason but that
is it that is it okay so first of all
let's cover the parent what is the
parent now the parent you might notice
is the same type as this class all right
so what this node class does is it has
an instance of another node
okay and the reason for that is we need
somewhere to trace our path so let's
talk about that quickly so hopefully now
this should be fine I don't think you
guys will mind having allow the stuff in
the way here so we'll make blue nor vs
blue yellow no I can't say that working
out orange so we've got our little
entity here who wants to get to this
point and that's fine but what happens
is as a path gets drawn as we work out a
path we need to know where we came from
and that's where the parent comes in so
basically the first node that we are at
is the node that we are going from it's
the I guess this start right that's the
finish this is the start now the start
has a node and and the starts parent
right so the starts parent is null this
is a horrible choice of color no all
right it's null so the start doesn't
have a parent because it's the first one
all the other ones though do have a
parent so this node over here will have
the parent of this node now that node by
itself does not automatically have the
parent of this node the reason this is
the parent is because as you can see
this is the path we choose so in other
words if we choose to go from this node
to this node that node that we came from
is this nodes parent right and then we
keep going like that and the reason we
need to store this parent is because
when we get to the finish we want to
trace the path that we used to get to
the finish so that we can then return
that path and actually do something with
it
like for example move an entity along
that path now in order to actually trace
back our steps we need we need each node
here to know which node led to this node
so this node has to know that this node
came to it right not this node this node
as nothing to do with us this is the
parent this is where we came from and
using that kind of recursion we can
actually trace back our steps to the
beginning all right that's what the
parent is used for now Jake F F cos J
cos and H cost are three calculations of
costs right and a cost is how much I
guess it costs to get to a path so in
other words if we roughly look at this
is going to be a cheaper cost cost is
almost like a distance all right think
of it that way it's gonna cost this is
pretty much this is a pretty low cost
path right if we go all the way around
here that's gonna be a higher cost right
because the distance is higher now these
three there's a bunch of different costs
here there's a heuristic cost there's an
actual node to node cost which is the J
cos and then there's the combination of
them which is called the F cost and
these three are actually used by the
a-star search algorithm to figure out
how it can actually find out what the
fastest what the shortest path
possible is because that's what that
would that that is what a star is all
about figuring out the shortest path to
a well see the word shortest isn't use
the word lowest cost is used and the
reason that's the case if I just shove
over here and get me give myself some
more room the reason we use the term
lower cost instead of just instead of
shortest is because picture this
scenario we've got this area here
alright we've got we just happen to have
I'm not gonna draw tiles here but we
just happen to have a river that's a
river that ends here
now rivers water right we can cross that
technically if we really need to but
we've got a player here and or an entity
because hey I didn't typically use a
player I've got the destination over
here now it would be a it would be a
shorter path to go from here to here
like that right but would it really be a
lot of cost because water might slow you
down a lot so technically it might be a
shorter in distance to go here but it
might be faster and thus lower cost to
go like that
an a-star will actually take in this
this like obstruction as a possibility
it won't just simply be like okay that's
not a wall we can pass it I'm going to
choose this path no if we give it the
necessary details it will actually go
ahead and say all right well I can cross
that technically but you know maybe
there's a faster way and it will explore
that and it will find the faster way
then I'll take into account both of
these paths and it will be like okay
this one's better I'm gonna go through
this way all right
that's why that's why cost is different
than I guess distance okay that's pretty
much it
all right an F cost is simply a
combination of these G cost let's talk
about J cost really quickly okay a J
cost is I guess it's almost like the
total node to node cost all right now
let's uh I really don't want to make an
you I really hang on let me just quickly
save this into pictures and I'll call it
I'll just call it shutout one whatever
because I like this diagram not that
it's very Nate but I like it alright
that's actually saved so let's picture
this a little scenario here I'll have to
draw my career again I really wish there
was a line to land what a desk
SketchBook Pro is what I'm using but I
don't think there is so that's a pity
alright so we've got a bunch of these
and these are all of course tiles and
then we've got a bunch of nodes which I
will draw with a paintbrush because it's
faster okay so we've got this stuff and
we'll make this black so we've got all
these nodes right and let's just say
we're traveling from point A to point B
yeah as we travel we have to work our
distances and we actually have to keep
track of how long this path is taking us
somehow we need to know we'll okay I go
this way I'll go this way I'll go this
way I'll go this way although there's a
hang on a minute where am I how long is
this path taking me okay we need to keep
track of how long it's been since the
start now for a very simple calculation
going this way is gonna cost more than
going this way right because it's
physically a bigger distance right if we
look at this distance by itself as
basically a triangle just probably say
let's just say that's one I should say
that's one one tile this would clearly
be the square root of two tiles right
this is a really basic trigonometry I
guess as long as this of course it is a
ninety degree angle and both the height
and width are both equal to the same
value here alright and this is roughly
one point four one that's a square root
of two so there's really basic maths
again an in-depth series would cover
this in much more detail but the point
is it's gonna be a longer distance going
this way rather than going left or right
or up or down going diagonal is actually
going to cost us more now we need to
keep track of this cost so once we go
well still it's going to be better than
going
like that and like that that's the other
thing you have to consider right going
this way and this way is of course more
expensive than going just this way
because it's two directions and that's
one plus one right which is two this is
a square root of 2 which is 1.41 1.41 is
of course lower than two so of course in
this case this would be the much
preferred path and then we can go this
way again although I think as dumb I
want to calculate it going this way
depending on a lot of things just
because that is the first occurring both
and it's cheaper but the point is we'll
get here eventually and one thing that
we need to consider now is okay well
once we're up to this node what is our
total cost as to start yeah let's figure
out how long it's been so that's where
this comes in in this case is square
root of 2 cool now we go this way
okay well now our distance is of course
the square root of 2 plus 1 yeah and
then from here onwards our distance is
again the square root of 2 all right
pretty simple stuff so I'm of course
eventually what we would get well a
value here but eventually what we what
this accounts to is something called J
cost yeah J cost is the sum of all of
our I guess node to node distance as
simple as that now what is the H cost
this is a big one probably it's bigger
than this one probably the G car the H
cost is actually just a direct distance
to the finish okay so J cos of course
being the the sum of all of the nodes
that we've been to so our current
distance from the start is our J cost
and now we need a distance from the
finish now a big factor comes in to this
we don't know how to get to the finish
yet that's the whole reason we're
calculating this path so we can't be we
can't go ahead and say ok well the J
cost at this location I switch to green
the J cost at this location is root 2
but the edge cost well clearly it's
gonna be one plus root 2 well no because
we don't know that we need to go this
way and then this way we don't know that
that's what we're trying to calculate
how can we know that we need to do we
need to use this path to get there yet
we don't at this point in time so edge
cost isn't actually the same way as it's
not calculated the same way as chair
cost it's simply a I guess it's just a
direct line it's direct like distance
like a as the bird flies distance right
which is just gonna look like this okay
it's just like that if it was here if it
was from here if we were on this node
the edge cost would be like that all
right and the way that we've we work it
out of course is simple trigonometry
again Pythagoras theorem
it's simply gonna be that squared plus
that distance squared and then all that
square root okay so essentially the the
start x squared plus the normal actually
that might take a bit of time work out
because we need to subtract the finish X
as well and then square it and then add
the Y and then squared the whole thing
we'll talk about this in more detail
next time but the point is it's just a
straight line direction and of course F
cost is simply going to be the total
cost so we've worked out both of these
costs individually great but the cost
that we're actually going to use to
govern them in other words to to
actually let the algorithm tell us what
the shortest path is is a combination of
these two because they're both equally
important and that will be the DF cost
plus the G cost which is otherwise known
as the F cost which is our total cost
for the current node and for the nodes
of explore now that is that is some
pretty in-depth stuff I did not want to
go this in depth and I probably won't be
in the future I'll probably save that
stuff for actual in depth videos but
that's all you need to know about J cost
edge cost and F cost as well as the tile
parents
so that's it that's gonna wrap up this
episode of game programming hope you
guys enjoyed it pretty good 99th episode
next time we're gonna take a look at
probably what are we doing probably
actually starting to implement this I
can work pretty much ready so we're
gonna actually start writing out the
algorithm next time and we should we
might finish it probably actually that'd
be great 100 finish yeah we'll probably
finish in next episode well at least
we'll finish the algorithm we won't
actually finish the the taught the
entities moving to their locations we
will finish the algorithm and we'll
start and finish the algorithm next
episode also if you guys want to
download these videos and watch them
offline you can certainly do that the
channel come forward slash I don't know
the link because I mean it but the
shadowkhan for side game programming
will guide you how to get there and you
can download these videos for $10 you
get basically all these episodes
available for download as well as a
package download them all at once so
otherwise you don't have to individually
download them and I'm in like 10 bucks
like that's pretty shape that comes down
at 10 cents per episode 10 cents per
episode ok so you guys really think my
videos are worth that little you can go
ahead and buy that and that of course
will support me and enable me to
continue making these videos so thanks
for watching if you guys did like it
please hit like button if we can hit 300
likes I'll make another video tomorrow
and I'll see you guys next time good bye
you